many of us crave to be more interesting
people
the question is
how might we become so
we rightly tend to associate being
interesting with achieving difference
from the norm with being able to serve
up some unusual and intriguing stories
and ideas but what might be the best way
to lay our hands on these one
prestigious thesis
tells us that we should try our best to
root out new and well-reviewed books and
articles
travel to remote places
and befriend people who are prominent in
the arts and business
this correctly latches on to something
that we should aim to be different
but it entirely overlooks that before
we've ever read a single book
gone to any foreign country or met any
nobel prize laureates
we are all compellingly different anyway
the problem is that we just don't allow
ourselves to come across as such
to get a taste for this pre-existing
level of originality imagine if we
placed a microphone in any of our minds
and listened closely in on the chatter
we would quickly find the most
surprising and authentically gripping
information
we'd realize that we were attracted to
some very unexpected people
often just the sort we weren't supposed
to have any feelings for
we'd realize that we had some
hilariously personal and shocking takes
on politics and society
and that we didn't agree with most of
the standard lines proposed to us by the
media
our anxieties fears hopes and
excitements would show a properly
distinctive and captivating pattern
we are though we try so hard never to
admit this to ourselves let alone anyone
else
already a real character
we understand this point in relation to
children
every child under seven is fascinating
they almost never do anything
interesting in the outside world but
it's the honest uncensored way in which
they report on their inner lives that
guarantees their interest
when they chit-chat about their granny
or their teacher or their take on their
dad
we're open-mouthed
we were once fascinating too
before we got overly worried about
seeming normal
there are of course some things we
should as we grow up take care not to
mention to spare others hurt
but a lot fewer than we think
when we next fear coming across as dull
we need only lean in more closely on the
data from our deep selves
we should and the habit may require a
little conscious effort to develop
get in touch with what we actually
believe
what emerges may sound odd but it is
also liable to be hugely charming
warm-hearted and comforting and a lot
closer to what people around the table
deep down feel too
than what was printed in today's
newspaper
everyone is interesting
so-called interesting people are simply
those who've allowed themselves to
listen in on and share with others a
selection of what is really going on in
their minds
they have not allowed self-hatred and
self-suspicion to block them from
disclosing their reality
they have been confident enough to
imagine that the truth about themselves
could be a pleasure for others to hear
and with a few obvious caveats it almost
certainly will be
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more